you can't comment about Hamas terrorist
chopping off baby's
heads here she is yesterday this is so
profoundly vile except that it's obvious
right except that it's obvious here she
is this how long is this video about 60
seconds it's about 60 seconds she cannot
say a word about beheaded babies raped
women burned children Slaughter of
Innocence watch watch this rat watch
this rat Scurry
away terrorists have cut off babies
heads and burn children alive do you
support Israel's rights to defend
themselves
against we're just going to go through
there you can't comment about Hamas
terrorist chopping off baby's
heads Congress do you have a comment on
Hamas terrorist talking off
head you have nothing to say about Hamas
terrorist popping out baby head
do you
condone what Hamas has done chopping off
baby Heads Burning children alive raping
women in the
street you have no comment about
children's heads being chopped
off Congressman why do you have a
Palestinian flag outside your office if
you do not condone what teror to
Israel do Israeli lives not matter to
you first off before I comment on
Rashida and I have no doubt that you
guys were going through the words that I
might say about her in just a moment um
that that girl who I want to give an
awful lot of credit to there that is a
journalist and I can actually call her a
journalist which is so refreshing
without using air quotes her name is
Hillary vaugh and she works over at Fox
um that was about 60 seconds of a rat
scurry
away who simply cannot say you know um
baby's head's being chopped off is
pretty bad like why couldn't she stop
for one second and say you know I don't
see the Israeli Palestinian conflict the
way you see it but yes these tactics
murdering pregnant women like there's
such an easy out here but she can't do
that because she is for it she is for it
and we don't have to equivocate we need
to stop being nice you know there are
too many of us too many of us have just
become sort of amoral wishy-washy we
will never stand up for ourselves as the
people come to get us as the murderers
calling from inside the house and in
this case inside the House of
Representatives okay she could not just
say you know actually um obviously I'm
more on the Palestinian side of this
thing and okay generally that's
different than maybe what you guys think
at Fox but yeah B you know the burning
of babies the beheading of babies we can
all get on board that one and she can't
cuz she's for
it